l'émotion de toute une famille après
l'assassinât de leur père lundi dernier
l'émotion de toute une communauté dans
les rues de fort de france
une marche silencieuse avec près de 500
personnes du jamais vu c'est une grande
première ce surtout la communauté
chinoise
l'awb a l'habitude de faire ce genre de
choses on a besoin de la sécurité lui
contre la violence donc attirer
l'attention de l'autorité
la marche était parti de la rue de la
république là même où la victime a été
abattu froidement par des hommes
encagoulés et armés autour d'un fort de
france et une arrivée aux abords de la
préfecture
une manifestation qui a touché la
famille surtout merci d'être venu vous
tous
non seulement pour le mordre dramatique
de mon père mais aussi nous tous les la
communauté chinoise nous tous les
commerçants on marque qui essaye de
travailler essaie de survivre en
martinique puisse avoir de la sécurité
et surtout merci merci d'être venus
merci une marche silencieuse à l'issue
de laquelle la colère explose c'est très
très dur très dur et on a du mal à
apprendre ça coule à quoi ces trois duos
date chez les gens gratuitement
c'est ma meilleure amie et on a toujours
été ensemble de vie qu'elle arrive en
martinique on se connaît et je venais
chez est très souvent et puis j'ai
partagé des moments avec son père puis
je l'apprécié c'était quelqu'un de bien
des gentils une marche qui a donc vu la
présence de martiniquais aux côtés de la
communauté asiatique présence de
commerçants de la ville des élus aussi
parmi lesquels le maire de fort de
france didier laguerre
on va pas le remplacer mais pour vous
aider à aller au bout puisqu'ils vont
pouvoir prendre la suite il faut pouvoir
faire les études etc
donc on va vous accompagner
ici en fait matinée une délégation a été
reçue en préfecture
la quasi totalité des commerces tenus
par les chinois étaient fermés
aujourd'hui